Also goes on to identify four levels of protection. This is of course
unprotected systems, so an unprotected system is
where there is no level of protection.
An example would be the early operating system for the personal computer, called
MS-DOS. And it had hooks, in the system for preventing mistakes by the user.
But there was no real protection. So mistake
prevention is not the same as securing a
system. That's important to see the distinction between
mistake prevention and a secure system. Now, let's
talk about the four levels of protection that,
salts are identified in this classic paper. The
first level is what he calls all or
nothing. An example of a system that implemented
that would be IBM's VM-370. And most of the time-sharing systems
of the 60s and the 70s, they had
this all-or-nothing property. For example, in the VM-370,
Each user was given the illusion as though
they have their own personal system. That's why it's
called a virtual machine and the only way
they can interact with one another is by explicitly
doing I/O from one virtual machine to another
virtual machine. That's the All-or-Nothing Property that VM-370 had.
The second level of protection is what results
are called controlled sharing, that is for example
having access lists associated with files, so that
an individual, if I create a file, I
could say my file can be shared by My students, and here are the names of
the students that have access to their file.
So that's an access list that you can associate
with information that you create and give to the system for safekeeping. That's
controlled sharing. Another level of protection
is what's also called user-programmed sharing controls.
Now this would be facilities similar to what you find in Unix file system today,
for instance, such as being able to associate different access rights for
files for different groups of users. In unix, for
instance, there are levels of protection that you can associate
with a particular file that you created. What is
the access right for the creator, the owner of the
file? What is the access right for a group
that is defined and what is the access right for
the rest of the world? So there are three
levels of, protection that you can associate of the file,
and that's an example of user
program sharing controls. Another level of protection
is having user defined strings on information. For instance, in the military it
is often common to have physical files labeled with top secret. That has
to be opened by only some privileged set of users. Similarly, you can associate
such strings on information that you create and
store with the system. There's four levels of
protection that I've identified here are not cast
in concrete, because as the system evolves, as the
user community evolves, You need to be able
to deal with the dynamics of use of this
information, use of the system. So that is
another issue which you can call as a cross-cutting
issue with respect to these levels of protection.
For example, how do I change the permissions
I've given to,a particular file to a set
of users that I've defined as a group that
can access that file. How do I change the set of users I've included in the
access list? What do I do to remove somebody from the access list? What do I do
to add someone to the access list for information that I've already created? So
all of these are issues that deal with the dynamics of use of information.